il est important de comprendre d'où
vient ce virus le virus de la cobi 19
pourrait-il provenir d'un laboratoire
que la
première partie d'une enquête troublante
sur les origines des virus qui a
bouleversé la planète
nous sommes en dessous du groupe au soir
de ces jeunes seulement un bar dundas
n'ont rien
bienvenue à découverte
[Musique]
le virus sras skov 2 qui a causé la
pandémie pourrait provenir d'un
laboratoire au
tout début cette hypothèse qui était
farfelu complotistes
un an et demi plus tard le ton a changé
l'hypothèse est devenu plausible la
bastidonne appel
commun c'est l'histoire que nous vous
raconterons au cours des deux prochaines
semaines
celles d'internautes qui dans l'ombre
ont investigué la question et des
scientifiques qui ont mis en péril leur
carrière pour mettre au jour des
informations troublantes
[Musique]
l'hypothèse est effrayante si elles
s'avèrent les répercussions cet immense
want to be propres au
bord d'une audace ni
une enquête scientifique complexe
brouillé par les intérêts politiques de
géant
après un an l'enquète sur les origines
l'aco vide dévoile le peu de contrôle
que nous avons sur les expériences
risquée menée sur les pathogènes les
plus dangereux de la planète du
supporter
elle projette le spectre d'un futur
possible une prochaine pandémie causée
par des virus créé par l'humain
l' enquête commence ici dans la ville de
wuhan en chine centrale
omar chirwan al
plus de 600 et al dix mille visiteurs
par jour côtoyant des animaux vivants
sauvage issus de commerce illégaux
selon les autorités chinoises les
premiers cas sont liés à ce marché c'est
pour cela que dès le départ pour
beaucoup il est évident que c'est ici
que le virus se seraient transmis pour
la première fois d'un animal à un humain
c'est l'avis du virologiste robert
garrigues la nouvelle orléans il est un
expert des maladies émergentes
il fait partie des premiers à examiner
les séquences génétiques du strass
cooptés
mais dès janvier 2020 sur les réseaux
sociaux circulent une autre hypothèse
celle d'une fuite de laboratoire
à une dizaine de kilomètres du marché se
trouve l'institut de virologie de ou
anne un complexe composé de plus d'une
vingtaine de laboratoires répartis sur
deux sites
cet institut est l'épicentre mondial de
la recherche sur les coronavirus de
chauves souris
en particulier depuis la pandémie de
strass en 2003 apparue en chine qui
avait mis toute la planète sur le qui
vive elle a révélé le risque posé par
les coronavirus
depuis la mission de l'institut étudié
les coronavirus pour prévenir une
prochaine pandémie
dès janvier robert gary se penche sur la
séquence génétique du virus avec
d'autres virologue de renault
le 17 mars 2020 avec ses collègues il
publie une lettre dans le journal nature
médecine en deux paragraphes il écarte
l'hypothèse d'une fuite de laboratoire
leur correspondance suit une autre
lettre influente parue dans la revue des
lands est signée par 27 scientifique ils
écrivent nous nous unissons pour
condamner les théories complotistes
suggérant que le virus n'aurait pas une
origine naturelle
à ce moment là leur argument semble
solide le strass cov 2 est trop
différent de tout virus répertoriés il
n'observe aucun signe visible de
manipulation sur la séquence génétique
du virus et les épidémies passé sont
d'origine animale ces deux lettres font
autorité
aux yeux du public et de nombreux
scientifiques il ya consensus des
experts
mais pas pour ali natcan une post
doctorante en thérapie génique au board
institut affilié au et mighty et à
harvard pour elle ces lettres ont
l'effet contraire
de fuck me like
ou prête en 2020 elle émerge comme une
des rares voix scientifiques sur twitter
a discuté publiquement la possibilité
d'une fuite de laboratoire elle souligne
les faiblesses de ces lettres
c'est que depuis des années les
chercheurs de l'institut de virologie de
wuhan échantillonne les endroits reculés
de la chine à la recherche des prochains
pathogènes susceptibles de causer une
pandémie les bourses européennes
cette vidéo promotionnelle donne un
aperçu de leur travail dans des grottes
infesté de chauves souris
sur
rodez
ils ont ainsi ramené à one plus de 22
mille échantillons criant une des plus
importantes collections de corona virus
de type strass au monde
dans leur laboratoire à roanne les
chercheurs mène de vastes programmes de
recherche pour étudier ces pathogènes
sauf
accident son standing des
facteurs un autre élément alimente ses
doutes avec robin wright limoges oui
votre rôle dans des voies ou s en fout
protecteur
mais plusieurs articles et reportages
passé sur l'institut de virologie
montrent le contraire
dring ben
ali vers 2020 la voie de la pause
doctorante ali natcan ne fait pas le
poids contre la liste imposante de
scientifiques de renom qui rejette
l'hypothèse d'une fuite de laboratoire
et surtout contre la crédibilité de
chizé muhly chercheuse à l'institut de
virologie de wuhan
elle est à la tête de ses travaux sur
les coronavirus de chauves souris si une
des plus grands experts mondial du
strass
elle est surnommée là-bas tout amène
en février 2020 alors qu'elle est au
coeur de la controverse elle écrit sur
le réseau social web os je jure sur ma
vie que ceci n'a rien à voir avec mon
laboratoire
mais on découvrira plus tard dans une
rare entrevue accordée au synthétique
américaine qu'elle a eu des doutes
causés par une interrogation capitale
la voici tous s'entendent pour dire que
l'ancêtre du strass coop deux premières
sans doute la chauve souris tout comme
ses proches par inconnu il aurait
probablement pour hôtes naturels la
chauve-souris rhinolophe or l'air de
répartition de cette chauve-souris se
situe à plus de 1600 km de wuhan
alors comment ce virus at-il voyagé
depuis cet habitat jusqu'à où anne et où
s'est-il transmis à l'humain oui donc
non
godfried danneels h pour
antoine à
la première réaction de shiso ni est
rapportée ici je n'aurais jamais pensé
que ce genre de choses pourraient
survenir à wuhan en chine centrale la
chercheuse en et si surprise qu'elle
croit que les autorités ont dû se
tromper que ça ne peut pas être
coronavirus
bauchet and
cheese lui envisage immédiatement une
fuite de laboratoire et rapportent en
avoir perdu sommeil ce n'est qu'après
avoir fouillé dans ses données qu'elle
aurait été rassuré
bref ce qui différencie les deux
hypothèses celle autres intermédiaires
selon l'hypothèse d'une origine
naturelle comme dans les épidémies passé
le virus aurait transité depuis la
chauve souris par un animal plus
semblable biologiquement animaux il se
serait alors rendu à one par la traite
des animaux vendus au marché
selon l'hypothèse de la fugue de
laboratoire ils se seraient transmises
sur les sites d'échantillonnage
directement de la chauve souris à
l'humain ou par des échantillons ramenés
à one
les interrogations dali natcan sont mal
reçus et sa réputation est mise à mal
mais ali natcan persiste et ses soupçons
ne feront que croître avec l'apport
d'internautes intrigués par les
multiples contradictions de l'institut
de virologie de wuhan
[Musique]
après la pause le manque de transparence
à l'ère des internautes mais aussi des
scientifiques
[Musique]
au printemps 2020 les hypothèses les
plus farfelues sur les origines lakovic
fusent
sur son compte twitter ali natcan
départage méthodiquement le déluge
d'informations celle plausible de sel
sans fondement
ces publications attire des internautes
déterminée a exploré l'hypothèse d'une
fuite de laboratoire
une vingtaine d'entre eux se regroupent
sous le nom de drastiques
beaucoup sont anonymes certains
irrévérencieux mais on y retrouve aussi
des scientifiques biologistes
immunologiste
et l'ingénieur francisco d assises d
ribera un analyste de données à madrid
ce qui réunit d'abord drastique c'est
ceci une publication de chizy de
l'institut de virologie de wuhan en
février 2020 elle y analyse le nouveau
virus sras skov 2 mai annonce aussi que
son laboratoire a en sa possession un
autre coronavirus est ratée g13 le plus
proche cousin connu du strass cov 2 à
96,2 % identique
une révélation dérangeante pour
drastiques ce qui les intrigue c'est le
peu de détails fournis sur la provenance
de ce nouveau virus
se joint à eux la microbiologiste
rossana segreto alors à l'université
d'innsbruck en autriche où
elle découvre que ce virus est déjà
répertoriés dans une base de données
mais sous un autre nom ils auraient été
prélevés dans la région du mode yagg
dans le sud de la chine
mignolet
[Musique]
les morceaux du casse-tête prennent
forme grâce à un autre membre de sea que
un jeune indien de 30 ans
il plonge dans une des bases de données
de publications académiques les plus
importantes de chine
ils y découvrent deux thèses supervisés
par des chercheurs chinois de renom
sa découverte confirme les soupçons de
drastique est ratée g13 a bien été
prélevés dans la région du mondial dans
une mine où est survenu un incident
grave en 2012
six mineurs qui contractent une forme
inconnue de pneumonie trois ans meurt
une des thèses décrit en détail les
symptômes et le traitement avec
radiographier à l'appui forte fièvre
toux douleurs corporelles difficultés à
respirer des symptômes similaires à la
cause id comme le confirmeront plus tard
plusieurs scientifiques
en mars shengli en entrevue confirme
avoir échantillonnés cette mine après
l'éclosion meuwly affirme que la maladie
était causée par un champignon actuel
est de
quatre démineurs porte des anticorps
spécifiques un virus de type strass
célèbre pneumologue chinois il est le
premier à avoir décrit le virus du
strass
un diagnostic d'une grande importance
scientifique
ce serait alors une première observation
d'une transmission directe de la chauve
souris à l'humain
une découverte qui a dû secouer les
scientifiques dans un pays marqué par le
premier sera ce
pays jean
drastique est convaincu d'avoir fait une
découverte exclusive
francisco des assisses poursuit il
plonge dans toutes les publications et
présentation de shenley il tient des
tableaux où il compile tous les virus
rapporté et croiser des bases de données
il déduit qu'en plus de est ratée g13
huit autres souches de virus de type
strass ont été prélevés dans la mine du
mondial
drastique questions à répétition
l'éditeur de nature qui a publié chez
only
finalement le 17 novembre 2020 shengli
publié en adam d'hommes à son article 2
février elle confirme les soupçons de
drastique entre 2012 et 2015 son équipe
est retourné deux fois par année à la
mine du monde gyan en prélevant 1322
échantillons dont est ratée g13 et huit
autres virus apparentés
ont dit
tout cela ne prouve en rien qu'il y a eu
une fuite de laboratoire mais témoigne
d'une absence de transparence
richesse
et cette absence de transparence est
encore plus troublante au sud et
expérience controversée menée depuis des
années à l'institut de virologie de
wuhan qui inquiète un autre groupe de
scientifiques cette fois avec assez
d'autorité pour influencer le débat
[Musique]
après la pause modifié à virus pour
qu'ils puissent infecter les humains
[Musique]
il de toutes les villes du monde la
pandémie a débuté à ou anne haut lieu de
la recherche sur les coronavirus de type
sera ce
une coïncidence qui préoccupe aussi
d'autres scientifiques plus discret dès
le début de la pandémie
les experts
philippe allen sauce et experte en
menaces biologiques au king's college de
londres elle conseille régulièrement
l'onu sur ces questions
je crois que
même interrogation de ce côté ci de
l'atlantique
de qui nous sommes
le biologiste richard et bright envisage
immédiatement la fuite de laboratoire
karawan l'institut de virologie est
réputé depuis des années pour ses
expériences contreversé
une forme d'expérience qui soulève le
débat depuis 2000
la commission identifie sept types de
recherche qui pose un risque élevé
nissan activité
parmi ses péchés une technique jusqu
alors jamais employé le gain de fonction
elle consiste à prendre des virus et par
manipulation génétique augmenter leurs
fonctions créant ainsi de nouveaux virus
jamais vu en nature plus transmissible
ou plus mortelles par exemple
du poulet et nouilles
pourtant c'est ce que feront deux
laboratoires dix ans plus tard tous deux
financés par les états unis ils
construisent un nouveau virus il est
dérivé du h5n1 virus aviaire qui lorsque
transmis à l'homme un taux de mortalité
de 60 % ils le rendent capable
d'infecter des mammifères par voie
respiratoire de soi vie
ceux qui mènent ces travaux le but est
de prévenir la prochaine pandémie c'est
new york on peut prédire la prochaine
pandémie de la grippe
c'était la fantasy nous ne pouvons pas
il ya des articles où on a bien cru
j'étais là et que c'était mission
impossible
inquiété par cette recherche simon
watson co-découvreur du vih est un des
premiers à alerter la communauté
scientifique
se posant y viennent fuite personnes
soit capable de projeter dans l'avenir
et prédire leur trajectoire même si le
risque est faible les conséquences
peuvent être gigantesque
richard et bright cocquerez le cambridge
working group
plus de 300 scientifiques qui réclame
une supervision gouvernementale du gan
fonction
leurs actions aboutissent en 2014 le
gouvernement obama ordonne un moratoire
sur les expériences de gan fonctions
considérées préoccupante
malgré la controverse malgré le
moratoire en 2015 ralph barriques un
chercheur américain en collaboration
avec cheese only de l'institut de
virologie de one présentent leurs
propres créations ces travaux sont alors
menées en caroline du nord à chapeau
riant
c'est le spicules cette protéine externe
du virus qui détermine quelles espèces
le coronavirus est capable d'infecter en
modifiant le spéculent il est alors
possible de l'adapter aux cellules
humaines
en 2010 cette chaîne il y reprend cette
technique mais cette fois dans son
laboratoire à one elle utilise comme
charpente des virus de type sera prélevé
lors de ses missions dans les grottes du
yunnan
cette publication n'est en fait que la
première étape d'un projet plus vaste
ces recherches sont financées encore une
fois par les états unis via un
intermédiaire et cohortes aux isles un
organisme dont la mission est de se
préparer à la prochaine pandémie les
présidée par peter d'azac un spécialiste
en maladies transmises par les animaux
les voici en entrevue en décembre 2019
peu avant la pandémie
sa vision est audacieuse employés le
guen fonctions afin de développer des
vaccins ou des médicaments avant même
l'apparition de la prochaine pandémie
et l'institut de virologie de one est au
coeur de ce plan
aucune publication du détail les
expériences menées à one après l'article
de 2017 pour comprendre ce qui s'y passe
il faut donc suivre la trace des
demandes de subventions celle déposée en
2018 sont révélatrices
laisserait
il emploie différents virus comme
charpente et inserts systématiquement
différents spicules l'objectif
identifier combien et quelles mutations
sont nécessaires avant que ces virus
chimères ne soit capable d'infecter les
cellules humaines
et ses travaux ont porté fruit on
l'apprend en novembre 2019 sur twitter
alors qu'un chercheurs contestent
l'utilité de ces recherches peter d'azac
rétorquent qu'ils ont identifié plus de
50 nouvelles souches capables de se lier
aux cellules humaines en employant des
virus recombinant ces virus chimère
est-ce que l'institut de virologie
aurait pu assembler des chimères à
partir de virus prélevés dans la mine du
mondial là même où ont été trouvés est
ratée g13 le plus proche parent connu du
strass cov 2 ainsi que huit autres virus
apparenté
à la barre jean
est ce que de telles expériences aurait
pu donner naissance ou sera skov 2
la réponse se trouve probablement dans
les ordinateurs de l'institut de
virologie
l'institut disposait d'une base de
données recensant les virus qu'ils
avaient en leur possession
mais un allié de drastiques découvre que
la base de données a été mise hors ligne
comme on peut le voir ici le 12
septembre 2019 deux mois avant la
pandémie
humaine
et shocking
questionné à ce sujet l'institut de
virologie se défend en répondant qu'elle
a été mise hors ligne suite à des
cyber-attaques d'état
malgré la présence d'une des plus
importantes collections de corona virus
de type sera son monde en plein coeur de
one
malgré la présence du virus est ratée
g13 le plus proche parent connu du
strass cov 2
malgré les découvertes de drastiques
malgré les expériences de gan fonction
qui suscite inquiétude depuis deux
décennies
malgré l'absence de transparence de
l'institut l'hypothèse d'une fuite de
laboratoire n'est pas prise au sérieux
elle est même ridiculisé
pourquoi follow the money comme disent
les américains
il faut suivre la piste de l'argent
[Musique]
après la pause principal bailleur de
fonds de ces recherches controversé les
états unis
[Musique]
au printemps 2020 le président des états
unis donald trump accuse l'institut de
virologie de wuhan d'être à l'origine du
virus
ces supporters se range derrière lui le
débat se politise à quel point le
gouvernement américain et est il
vraiment préoccupés par la possibilité
d'une fuite de laboratoire on l'a appris
que récemment par une enquête
journalistique dans la revue vanity fair
on ne connaît que trois laboratoires
dans le monde qui mène ce genre
d'expérience de gan fonction sur les
coronavirus de type strass en caroline
du nord à châteaubriant au laboratoire
de ralph barriques à l'université du
texas mais le coc brunch à galveston et
à l'institut de virologie de wuhan en
chine tous financés par le gouvernement
américain
à la tête de cet institut le docteur
anthony facci minutes et lui même qui
pendant la pandémie sera la figure de
proue de la guerre américaine contre
lacko vide
pendant plus d'une décennie anthony
facci à subventionner et défendu les
recherches sur le gain de fonction
il écrit dans cette lettre d'opinion que
c'est un risque qui en vaut la peine et
dès janvier le docteur march é est
alerté par la possibilité d'une fuite de
laboratoire par robert gary et ses
collègues virologue
nous vous en parlions plus tôt ils sont
les auteurs de cette lettre dans nature
medicine qui a fait autorité dès le
début de la pandémie écartant de façon
décisive la possibilité d'une fuite de
laboratoire mais quelques semaines à
peine avant la publication la lettre
leur opinion était très différente
leur échange de courriels avec anthony
faraci rendues publiques récemment par
la loi d'accès à l'information dévoile à
quel point leurs doutes étaient
importants le 31 janvier 2020 par
courriel christian anderson un collègue
de robert gary note une caractéristique
inhabituel et veut voir de plus près si
ces virus sont potentiellement construit
en laboratoire il note que cette
caractéristique est incompatible avec
les attentes de la théorie de
l'évolution
ce qui les perturbe c'est ce qu'on
appelle un site de clivage de furie un
élément sur le speaker du virus qui
facilitent l'entrée dans les cellules
humaines
à marseille en france le virologue
etienne decroly repère aussi cette
caractéristique est un fait part à son
collègue bruno canard
la première réaction qu'on a eue quand
on a découvert ce site c'est en tout cas
une inquiétude certaine c'est le 1t 90
nice qui est d'insérer ce site inquiète
car depuis des années les scientifiques
insère des sites de clivage de furie
pour faire du gain de fonction et rendre
des virus plus infectieux dans la
littérature scientifique on retrouve
toute une série de travaux de recherche
dans laquelle les chercheurs de
différents laboratoires dans le monde
compte insérer ce type de suite
justement pour essayer de comprendre le
rôle de deux de ses sites de protéolyse
dans la pathogenèse du virus et d'un
point de vue évolutif ce site est
inattendu les coronavirus dans la
famille du sart ce n'avait pas de site
de clivage à la furie sauf ceux qui ont
atterri ce numéro 2 qui en a évident
unique
alors qu etienne decroux l'iran cette
découverte publique le débat fait rage
et les spécialistes pour certains ce
site aurait pu apparaître de manière
naturelle mais pour d'autres sa présence
est le signe évident d'une manipulation
de laboratoire
pour les virologues français il est
incompréhensible que robert yari ses
collègues aient pu trancher si
rapidement sur l'origine du virus est
publiée sitôt cette lettre qui écarte la
fuite de laboratoire on a été tout de
suite frappé évidemment par une
impression d'un parti pris qui était
pris
par les auteurs alors même que pour nous
la question était vraiment beaucoup plus
ouverte que ce que ce n'était indiquée
dans cet article de science
la découverte de ce site de furie en
tout cas suffisamment inquiété anthony
facci pour convoquer une réunion au
lendemain des courriels samedi 1er
février
et
l'article du vanity fair révélera
comment des membres du gouvernement
américain ont ensuite tenté d'étouffer
la conversation sur la fuite de
laboratoire refusant d'ouvrir la boîte
de pandore
en
mars 2021 le virologue robert redford
accordera une entrevue choc à sionnel il
était le directeur du center for disease
control au début de la pandémie
anthony facci se défendra d'avoir
banalisé l'hypothèse la fille de
laboratoire
en avril 2020 en pleine pandémie après
plus d'une décennie de financement la
haine et met abruptement fin à la
subvention des covers rhymes
le gouvernement américain n'est pas
seule à être embarrassée par la thèse la
fuite de laboratoire
et qu il aille on semble être aussi
revenons aux lettres qui ont fait
autorité au début de la pandémie
celle-ci publié dans des 27 qui qualifie
de complotiste la théorie d'une fuite de
laboratoire regardons l'impressionnante
liste de 27 signataires on apprendra
plus récemment que parmi eux 26 ont des
liens avec l'institut de virologie
parmi eux cinq qui travaille pour eco
art heinz et son président peter d'azac
qui a rédigé puis orchestré la signature
de cette lettre
pourtant les auteurs écrivent nous ne
déclarons aucun conflit d'intérêts
un an après le début de la pandémie le 7
janvier 2021 au soir après de longs mois
de tergiversations internes le
département d'état des états unis
invitent les experts pour discuter des
éléments scientifiques qui soutiennent
une fuite de laboratoire parmi les 29
invités ralph barriques l'ancien
collaborateur de shengli et alina
china
daily
la conférence sera tenue confidentielle
tous les yeux sont alors tournés vers l'
enquête à venir de loin ms oui au 8 août
2010 ou safari entre 2001 ou dab willy
to understand what happened
après la pause un rebondissement de
dernière heure
cette semaine une nouvelle vient
bouleverser la donne drastique vient de
rendre publique une demande de
subvention des isles soumise à la
défense américaine dix huit mois avant
le début de la pandémie
cette demande dévoile un projet
impliquant l'institut de virologie de
wuhan elle propose d'introduire sur des
coronavirus de type strass des sites de
clivage de furie
une découverte choc parce que cette
caractéristique génétique est aussi
présente sur le sera ce kof 2 elle
soulève les soupçons depuis un an car
pour plusieurs elle est un signe d'une
manipulation en laboratoire
pourtant ce projet dirigé par peter
d'azac n'a jamais été rendue publique
jusqu'à présent la défense américaine a
refusé cette demande mais d'autres l'ont
dit ils financent et on le sait pas
encore mais c'est une preuve écrite des
intentions de l'institut et une autre
coïncidence dérangeante
ne manquez pas la suite dimanche
prochain de la part de toute l'équipe
merci d'avoir été là bonsoir
[Musique]